On the left he puts what most people often think of as the first part of
this process, acquiring and munging data.
And often this is what takes the most time.
On the right, Ben places interactive data visualization,
which is typically what people think of as the final product.
A pretty chart, a graphic once all the hard work has been done.
Ben places the domain he thinks most naturally fits above each stage.
The first of which being computer science.
In the larger context of data visualization, or data science as a whole,
the acquire and parsing stages are often concerned with data ingestion
be it web scraping, log collection, database accesses, et cetera.
And building scalable extract transform and load pipelines, or ETL.
A second group here of filtering and mining represents what is often most
associated with data science, and many people consider it the most exciting.
This includes modeling, data mining, and exploratory analysis, and
applying statistical and mathematical theory to discover insights.
Because of this,
Ben Fry labels the second stage as associated with statistics and data mining.
While people often think the second stage is, so
to say, where the magic happens and the models are built.
I really want to stress the importance of the process as a whole.
After all,
if you didn't have any data in a readily accessible form, you couldn't model it.
And even once you have a model, if you can't present and
communicate your results.
They might as well never have happened.
The third stage here focuses on the visual representation of your data, and
how you present it graphically, thus is most associated with
the fields of graphic design and visualization theory.
It is in this third stage that we experiment with different visual encodings to
present our data in the most effective manner.
And the fourth stage here is concerned with how a reader or
your audience might interact with your visualization.
Techniques from the field of information visualization and
human computer interaction apply here,
to determine how best to design your graphic or visualization such that it
enables your user to potentially discover insights for themselves.